et et
[Musique]
et
crise
[Musique]
et
bienvenue dans le 50e trois théories de
la chaîne et je peux vous assurer que
l'émotion est là
cela fera quatre ans en janvier que je
vous propose ce format et je suis
toujours autant passionné je peux vous
assurer qu on ira jusqu'au sang mais à
l'heure actuelle pour fêter ça
j'aimerais vraiment vous proposer une
vidéo qui vous le détour et c'est pour
ça que je vous sors l'une de mes plus
grandes passions
l'univers dunderdale et de delta runes
créé par toby fox
néanmoins ce n'est pas suffisant pour
marquer l'événement et c'est pour ça que
j'ai fait appel à du renfort à un
vidéaste que j'admire vraiment beau
coucou et bienvenue dans ce trois
théories sur delta rhune bonjour argot
rock ça fait très plaisir de me
retrouver sur ta chaîne j'espère vous
allez apprécier la vidéo
oh
et
[Musique]
malgré ce qui a été affirmé par toby fox
il est difficile de ne pas lier
undertake et delta rhune ok nous sommes
bel et bien dans une nouvelle histoire
et une nouvelle dimension
tout ce qui s'est passé dans under tail
reste dans under tail mais justement ce
côté dimensions ce côté miroir implique
forcément un lien avec la dimension
passé de par la réutilisation des mêmes
personnages mais dans d'autres
circonstances
ou tout simplement la ressemblance entre
les deux univers alors après c'est
également une technique permettant
d'avoir déjà des bases instaurées pour
que le joueur ne se perdent pas tout en
impliquant du fan service en réutilisant
les personnages dont nous sommes déjà
fan mais justement le lien se crée
automatiquement
prenons tout d'abord l'exemple de crise
la ressemblance avec kara est flagrante
par rapport aux vêtements et le fait que
nous incarnons en humain je sais que
c'est un argument que vous avez entendu
et réentendu
mais il a son importance suite à nos
actions dans la route génocide tail
carano propose de passer au monde
suivant et cela pourrait bien n'être
delta rue et justement c'est ça le
toubib fox nous affirme que delta run
n'a aucun rapport avec candeur tail mais
il pourrait clairement s'agir d'un dire
permettant de se dédouaner de devoir
faire une suite
under tail nous savons que tony fox
possède une pression énorme par rapport
à l'engouement que créateur tail faire
une suite d'après lui pourrait décevoir
et c'est compréhensible gros respect à
lui mettant la nomine dog est un sacré
troll il se pourrait que delta run soit
bel et bien lié à un orteil de près ou
de loin
nous sommes d'ailleurs toujours dans le
même univers mais une dimension
différente
prenons l'exemple das réel si vous
terminez la fin pacifique et que vous
retournez au tout début du jeu là où
vous êtes tombé vous tomberez sur abriel
qui vous affirmera que si vous le voyez
dans le futur il ne faudra pas le
confondre avec lui que c'est un autre
personnage
cela fait très clairement référence à
rezaï que nous voyons dans le dark world
et dont chacun a déjà fait le
rapprochement
ou encore tout simplement la légende de
la delta runes la dta runes est le
symbole de la famille royale dans under
tail comme nous le voyons sur les habits
de
temps réel où la tunique das gore et là
où ça devient très intéressant c'est par
rapport au concept de dimension instauré
par delta runes déjà fun fact nous
sommes à moitié dans un miroir les
monstres vivants à la surface et nous
avons la présence que d'un seul humain
ait eu beaucoup pensent que l'humanité
pourrait vivre sous terre cela reste
plausible ou encore par rapport au
système de choix dans under tail nos
actes ont des conséquences et nous
réfléchissons à deux fois avant
d'affronter quelqu'un alors que dans
delta rhune
nous sommes prévenus dès le début que
nous ne sommes pas vraiment acteur mais
plutôt viewer est là où je voudrais en
venir c'est que le joueur soit ne vient
perturber les équilibres de delta rhune
je m'explique comme si nous avions
changé de dimension delta runes dès le
début du met en garde par rapport au
fait que nous n'avons pas le choix comme
si le je savais que nous avions joué à
under tail auparavant creis mener sa vie
normale avant que nous le joueur vienne
pour interagir avec son corps nous en
avons la preuve avec tauriel ou encore
noël qui juge le comportement de crise
comme différent de d'habitude
à noter que puisque rencontré la même
symbolique dans dirt elle nous pouvions
le renommé et choisir et agir à sa place
nous ne savions d'ailleurs pas qu'il
s'appelait frisk enfin à part si vous
étiez un petit malin qui sait spoiler le
jeu avant d'y jouer mais dans l'idée
nous étions juste l'humain pour pouvoir
s'immiscer dans le jeu et le monde des
mortels
ici c'est exactement pareil sauf que
chris est quelqu'un de connu dans la
ville
il avait déjà réellement une vie avant
que nous arrivions alors que nous ne
savions rien sur ce risque
pas même son sexe c'est un ou une
humaine que nous incarnons un corps le
truc c'est que malgré le fait que nous
n'ayons aucun choix nous influent quand
même sur crise ce que je veux dire c'est
que chris est quelqu'un de très timide
et qui parle peu nous en tant que
joueurs nous souhaitons découvrir le
monde de delta runes et nous allons donc
parler à tous les pnj
ce qui veut dire que nous changeons le
comportement initial de crise car nos
joueurs apportant notre façon d'être en
crise la scène de fin pourrait donc
signifier que chris souhaite se
débarrasser de l' influence du joueur
sur lui et se serait pourquoi la cage
serait présente pour enfermer l'âme du
joueur comme si deux personnes étaient
dans le corps de christ et qu'à un
moment
ça suffit le détail apporté par la cage
nous montre que ce n'est pas la première
fois que cela arrive et que du coup ce
ne serait pas non plus la dernière fois
dans la métaphore nous pourrions
également le prendre dans le sens où
toby fox ou souhaite que nous arrêtions
d'avancé dans ce premier chapitre
tout simplement car le jeu n'est pas
fini il va falloir arrêter d'y jouer
pour le moment est ce que j'aimerais
rajouter c'est justement le rapport avec
la voix du début que beaucoup pensent
être gastr étant brisée à travers le
temps et l'espace gastr est interdite
mentionnait lé l'introduction du jeu se
passant indirectement au renders télé
hors d'elle tard une
cela expliquerait son accueil si c'est
bel et bien lui
et justement je soupçonne que certains
personnages seraient capables de voyager
à travers les dimensions prenons par
exemple jerson jerson et le vendeur de
waterfall dans under tail dans delta
runes jerson est déclaré comme mort et
nous avons même sa pierre tombale dans
le cimetière
si je parle de lui c'est parce que
jerson est le personnage qui nous
apprendra le plus sûr toute l'histoire
et la légende de la delta rue ce qui
pourrait dire que ce dernier fait le
voyage de del theron jusqu'à under tail
et de par sa disparition dentelle tard
une ce dernier aurait été déclaré comme
mort ou sinon le plus intrigant en reste
sens
nous savons tous ici que c'en est un
personnage hors du commun comme une
sorte de modérateur dunderdale
ce dernier est un réel savants comme son
repaire secret il en sait énormément sur
le temps et l'espace comme nous montrait
le moment où nous allions dans sa
chambre pendant votre aventure de
landert elle est d'ailleurs la vendeuse
de ce no dig nous apprenait également
que personne ne savait vraiment d'où lui
et papyrus provenaient mais qu'ils
étaient arrivés récemment et s'étaient
installés ici dans des tares une scène
et le sol des personnages que nous
connaissions grâce à hunter tel le seul
à avoir toujours la même tenue et c'est
un détail important
ce dernier vient d'ouvrir un magasin et
comme nous pouvons le remarquer sur la
pancarte salle a gribouillé ce qui avait
été écrit pour justement et écrire sant
genre chez sam's ce magasin qui vient
d'ouvrir est exactement le même que le
restaurant bar chez ghribi dont nous
savons que c'en est très fan de cet
endroit et y est très populaire et dans
delta runes c'est comme s'il avait amené
ce magasin et gribouillé la pancarte
pour écrire son nom
c'est très intrigant sens à toutes les
capacités requises pour voyager à
travers les dimensions
il est presque certain que nous sommes
face aux même sens que celui de
undertake bref c'est à vous de voir et
de juger mais dire à mes propos passons
à la suite
étant donné que la vidéo sort dix mois
après ce que j'avais prévu
oui des fois j'abuse car certains sujets
me font peur c'est le cas avec delta rue
j'ai décidé de remanier ce que j'avais
écrit à l'époque pour vous apporter plus
de nouveautés et éviter de répéter ce
qui a été dit maintes et maintes fois
par d'autres bien que ce que je vous
partage ne viennent que du plus profond
de ma tête
évidemment parlons donc du cas de noël
soit the lost girl un personnage qui
risque d'être mis au devant de la scène
dans les prochains chapitres de delta
toby fox a récemment tweeté des éléments
sur delta entre temps justement de noël
et cela peut sembler être anodin mais au
contraire il y a des choses à dire
déjà qu'ils aient noël
[Musique]
noël est une camarade de classe de crise
c'est une très bonne élève et vit dans
la partie nord-ouest de home town noël
est un monstre qui s'apparente à un
rennes et son nom se référencent
justement au mot noël dont l'animal
référer à l'instant en est le symbole
elle est la fille de la mairesse d'orgue
thorn et de rudy son père actuellement
hospitalisé pour une maladie inconnue
noël est une camarade timide mais très
amicale elle a du mal à démontrer ses
sentiments et son père l'a décrit comme
quelqu'un de sans défense voire même de
fragile descriptif accentuée par le fait
qu'elle ait peur de tout toby fox l'a
démontré de par ses tweets noël risque
de prendre de l'ampleur dans le futur de
delta rue le thème de lost girl traduit
parfaitement la description du
personnage
une jeune fille perdue sans défense est
prise par la peur mais nous pouvons
aller encore plus loin
de par les images partagées par toby fox
nous remarquons que noël va atterrir
dans le tarp world à un moment précis du
jeu
ce lost girl pourrait donc également
signifier la venue de noël par erreur
dans ce mystérieux monde se retrouvant
seul et sans défense id est accentuée
par l'image représentant noël seul dans
un look plus dark world que la vie
réelle
alors attention à ce que je vais vous
dire cela n'engage que moi et ma pensée
mais si noël devient de plus en plus
importante dans l'histoire cela veut
dire que le personnage va évoluer va
grandir comme nous avons eu le cas avec
suzy par exemple il est obligé pour moi
que malheureusement redis nous quitte
dans les prochains chapitres de delta
rue créant un électrochoc dans la vie de
noël et qui accentuerait donc encore
plus cette idée de the lost girl
car elle n'est pas proche de sa mère que
nous voyons absente du jeu est plus
occupé par son métier que sa famille il
redit sur son lit d'hôpital demande même
à crise de garder un oeil sur noël à
l'avenir étant donné qu'il ne peut plus
vraiment le faire à cause de sa maladie
il s'inquiète pour sa fille d'ailleurs
l'idée que noël rejoignent le groupe
dans le dark world n'est vraiment pas à
négliger
nous savons déjà qu'elle est une sorte
de béguin pour suzy dans l'intrigué
il se pourrait que cette dernière
finissent par erreur dans le dark world
et que chris et suzie partent en mission
sauvetage pour justement sauver cette
dernière ensuite j'aimerais qu'on creuse
une certaine partie du sujet
nous ne savons pas réellement d'où
provient le dark world la théorie du
rêve est très probable mais trop cliché
est détesté pour que toby fox s'en
inspire et justement suzy crise et donc
possiblement noël sont allés dans le
dark world
donc cela prouve la légitimité de ce
monde beaucoup pensent ray et c'est
d'ailleurs assez mon cas que caster soit
en quelque sorte l'un des précurseurs
alors oui c'est très vite avancé il n'y
a pas vraiment d'argument megastore est
trop important pour n'être qu'un simple
personnage de l'ombre et le
questionnaire de l'introduction de del
tard une colle parfaitement avec la
nature de caster se passe en justement
or under tale est hors d'elle tard une
hashtag morizet à travers le temps et
l'espace
mais nous nous égarons j'aimerais
beaucoup vous parler plus en détails de
caster un jour à voir si vous êtes
réceptifs et motivés l'idée que je
voulais vous transmettre et que le monde
extérieur est relié à celui du dark
world crise et suzie ondes l'excusent
d'être des élus entre guillemets d'une
légende d'une prophétie alors que
normalement
bah pas noël ce qui veut dire que si un
personnage normalement lambda comme noël
et réussi à finir dans le dark world
c'est que d'autres le peuvent et le
pourront et donc que le monde extérieur
est un impact plus important que l'on
pourrait le penser sur ce dernier
et peut-être même être à l'origine du
désordre provoqué dans ce monde
[Musique]
alors il est vrai des le terrain nous
laisse avec un paquet de questions qui
resteront sans réponse pour le moment
mais le premier chapitre est comme une
route parsemée de petits indices à nos
joueurs de démystifier ce qui nous a été
proposé
partant directement dans le vif du sujet
the king n'est évidemment pas le boss
final du jeu le véritable antagonistes
pourrait s'apparenter plutôt incertain
chevalier introduit par les dialogues du
king mais également de chaume et jay
ville alors qui est ce mystérieux
personnage
d'après ce qui nous est dit dans le
premier chapitre le chevalier quelqu'un
de très puissant
un personnage qui a le pouvoir de créer
des fontaines des ombres et qu'à la base
le dark world était dirigée par 4,3
respectivement le roi de trèfle pic
carreaux et coeur cependant le chevalier
figure apic le monarque absolu de ce
monde obscur et ans ferme à l'e3 au dans
une prison le roi pic et donc au service
de ce chevalier et semble même le
craindre d'après ce qu'il dit de notre
combat face à lui et enfin shawn nous
affirme que gvt il aurait pété rendu fou
par ce fameux chevalier puis enfermé
pour finir par nous dire qu'il faut
faire attention à lui vient je ne vais
pas vous le cacher j'ai deux idées qui
pourraient correspondre à ce chevalier
le monde de delta one résonne comme une
sorte de coffre à jouets et de jeux de
société les dirigeants correspondent à
un jeu de cartes traditionnelles en gros
quatre rois symbolisant trèfle pic coeur
et carreaux mais le roi de pique est
émise au pouvoir au détriment des autres
c'est l'élément important
il est donc un rapport avec un jeu de
cartes je vous avoue que j'ai tout
d'abord pensé à faire un rapprochement
avec le tarot ou la carte cavaliers et
présente cavaliers pouvant se traduire
également par knight et nous savons que
dans la boutique officielle dunderdale
des cartes de tarot à l'effigié des
personnages sont vendus néanmoins ce
n'est pas la représentation qui nous est
donnée au moment où crise et suzie sont
de retour dans le monde réel
au vu des cartes sur le sol par ton
plutôt sur un jeu de cartes
traditionnelles
nous réfléchissons logiquement nous
devons trouver une carte supérieure à
celle du roi et plus précisément celle
du roi de pique
ce qui expliquerait l'élection du roi de
pique en tant que monarque suprême le
chevalier pourrait symboliser un as et
plus particulièrement l'as de pique
ce serait l'explication logique las
étant la plus grande partie du temps la
carte la plus forte d'un jeu de cartes
traditionnelles
pour en revenir à jay ville on nous dit
qu'il a été rendu fou par le chevalier
puis enfermé pourquoi et bien tout
simplement car jay ville symbolise la
carte joker cependant le joker est à
double tranchant
effectivement un joker peut être traduit
comme un looser un bouffon d'où la
référence aux bouffons du roi c'est
d'ailleurs une connotation que l'on
retrouve un petit peu dans la nature de
jay ville ce personnage un peu fous mis
de côté comme la plupart du temps où la
carte du joker n'est pas prise en compte
dans un jeu de cartes
néanmoins le joker peut aussi de
considérer comme un bonus un bonus
permettant souvent de remplacer
n'importe quelle carte dans un jeu si
nous le prenons en compte et donc
devenir en quelque sorte la carte la
plus puissante du jeu et c'est
actuellement le cas de jay ville il peut
donc tout faire et contrôler à la fois
chaque et les brand pic tref carreaux et
coeur ce qui pourrait expliquer sa mise
à l'écart à cause du chevalier de peur
qui lui met des bâtons dans les roues et
le mettre en échec étant une carte
supérieure à tout le monde mais passons
au deuxième cas de figure permettant
d'approfondir le premier procès dans
quelques faiblesses le chevalier serait
un personnage extérieur du monde de
delta rhune
je m'explique déjà si le chevalier
réellement l'as de pique cela signifie
qu'il ya donc trois autres chevaliers
symbolisant l'as de trèfle carreaux et
de coeur ou sont ils dans ce cas ce
serait t'il débarrasser d'eux
malheureusement je n'ai pas de réponse à
cela mais le schéma pourrait être
reproduit par rapport à ce que sont
advenus les autres rois néanmoins il
existe des éléments étranges par rapport
à cette idée le chevalier est décrit
comme le chevalier est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement puissant et d'étranges
déjà le fait qu'il soit nommé ainsi
souligner ce côté d'unicité qu'il soit
seul agir ensuite le mot étrange n'est
pas utilisée par hasard et pourrait très
certainement signifier que le chevalier
serait étrange entre guillemets pour le
monde delta rue soit qu'il est à la base
un personnage extérieur du dard quoi si
nous comparons avec chris et suzie ces
derniers proviennent du monde extérieur
et à l'intérieur du monde de tels tard
une ils deviennent des personnages très
puissant des élus alors oui l'existence
de la légende vient perturber un petit
peu l'idée mais nous serions sur
exactement le même schéma soit que les
êtres extérieures soient supérieurs en
terme de pouvoir dans le dark world le
chevalier a le pouvoir de créer des
fontaines des ombres est considéré par
le roi qui est un être déjà très
puissant dans le monde tels tard une
comme un souverain utile je serais
personnellement très peu étonné qu'il
soit juste une réincarnation d'un
personnage hors dark world est justement
l'idée que d'autres personnages de
l'univers interviennent dans le dark
world est soulignée par la présence de
noël comme l'a démontré les tweets de
toby fox alors évidemment la question de
l'identité du chevalier fait
obligatoirement surface énormément pense
à gastes heures et c'est tout à fait
compréhensible caster est un historique
beaucoup trop présent pour n'être qu'un
simple fantasme des fans
le questionnaire de début du jeu le
téléphone dans le dark world le bunker
mettre son nom comme pseudo bref encore
une fois gastr fait partie de l'univers
brisé à travers le temps et l'espace
il écoute et voit tout et franchement ce
n'est qu'un fantasme purement personnel
et subjectif mais j'aime l'idée que
caster sur le personnage ou le boss
ultime des créations de toby fox celui
qui pourrait conclure tout son épopée
le jour où tony fox déciderait d'arrêter
son univers mais bref je m'égare
enfin j'ai envie de vous dire que les
absents ont toujours tort effectivement
deux personnages manquent à l'appel dans
delta runes et leur absence pourrait
signifier leur présence dans le dark
world
rien ne se passe hormis un cliquetis dos
distants imaginez si papyrus ne se
montre pas qu'un justement il pourrait
avoir un rapport avec le dark world ou
encore à ce réel qui est à l'université
effectivement il avait été souligné
qu'il ne fallait pas comprendre raissi
qui est d'ailleurs un anagramme d'abriel
avec ce dernier mail excuses de
l'université pourrait souligner la
présence de ce dernier dans le dark
world franchement je pense que ça à
méditer alors qui pourrait être ce
fameux chevalier la pyrrhus adriel un
personnage hors dark world ou un simple
antagonistes pouvant symboliser hélas
depuis par exemple à vous de débattre
dans les commentaires et me partager
votre interprétation et n'oubliez pas
que tout ce que je vous propose ne
reflète que ma propre pensée merci à
tous d'avoir regardé ce 50e trois
théories de la chaîne j'ai été vraiment
très honoré de parler de delta runes et
j'espère qu'à l'avenir on aura
l'occasion de reparler encore des
oeuvres de toby fox mais j'ai été encore
plus honorés d'avoir la présence dans la
vidéo d'un dvi d à ce que j'admire le
plus sur youtube
ico c'est aussi un grand passionné des
oeuvres de toby fox est également de la
pop culture et plus généralement le jeu
vidéo
je pense très sincèrement que vous le
connaissez tous ici mais si ce n'est pas
le cas n'hésitez pas à aller voir son
travail très sincèrement et surtout un
très grand merci à lui merci argot rock
pour me laisser passer sur ta chaîne
c'est très gentil et je te souhaite
d'avoir un milliard d'abonnés et de vue
j'aimerais également souligné le travail
du vidéaste captain hype
on peut passer à côté de ce qu'il a
produit sur les deux univers de toby fox
sur ce on se retrouve très prochainement
pour d'autres futurs trois théories
hashtag route ou deux sens et ce hashtag
marche aussi pour le nombre d'abonnés
est évidemment un
n'hésitez pas à venir me suivre sur
twitter ou encore instagram à me laisser
un gros pouce bleu et un commentaire sur
cette vidéo ou encore vous abonner à la
chaîne écoutez cet argot rock et puis
que le live earth soit avec vous bisous
et
[Musique]
lloris